bonjour et bienvenue dans fit l'écho ce
numéro est consacré au télétravail ce
mode d'organisation qui permet de
travailler en dehors des locaux de son
employeur ou de son client
alors quel intérêt y at il qui sont ces
télétravailleurs pour le savoir nous
irons à la rencontre d'un salariés
d'entreprises qui travaille de temps en
temps à domicile mais également des
indépendants qui ont opté pour un mode
de travail en commun dans un espace de
coworking
et pour faire un premier point sur ce
concept je vous propose de retrouver
gérard vallet président de la nd et et
l'association nationale pour le
développement du télétravail à la cité
des métiers là ndt organise
régulièrement des ateliers d'information
gérard vallet le président a découvert
le télétravail dans les années 80
informaticien de formation il
travaillait pour les responsables des
ressources humaines
j'ai un valet bonjour bonjour qu'est ce
qui vous attire et concrètement dans ce
concept est pourquoi avoir réalisé la
saison vraiment que d'une part on
s'apercevait qu'il y avait de
l'absentéisme qui avait évidemment de
fausses raisons qui poussent les gens à
déclarer des choses pour ne pas être là
qui te pas la réalité alors que c'est
simplement parce que le petit avait la
grippe ou que le train de fonctionner
plus et qu'on pouvait très bien ces
journées-là éviter de perdre un chalet à
éviter de faire de la productivité pour
le chef d'entreprise
donc le télétravail me semble sans
procès de façon tout à fait naturelle
au fil des années avec internet en
cuisine alors effectivement en 93 n'y a
pas du tout internet après le mini
callari l'on commence à faire pas mal de
choses avec le minitel et puis
l'internet massés ce grand frère du
minitel et là on peut véritablement avec
la miniaturisation des ordinateurs
portables commence à envisager très
sérieusement de ne plus avoir à se
déplacer en 1994
un an après le premier rapport sur le
télétravail par thierry breton
il crée la ndt moi ce que vous
considérez à l'époque 7 sur le seul
développement du télétravail au sol
politique
ça allait prendre du temps ce que je
voulais c'était faire des remontées du
terrain à la fois des entreprises des
salariés un gouvernement pour que
d'autres visions du télétravail soit
prise en considération
selon gérard vallet la définition du
télétravail restent floues on compte les
salariés qui travaillent certains jours
de chez eux mais aussi les travailleurs
indépendants et n'a une idée un petit
peu du nombre de télétravailleurs
l'époque où commença que le travail avec
un ordinateur et internet ont considéré
que gens qui travaillent chez eux à mi
temps ou à plein temps avec l'ordinateur
aujourd'hui le tableau change un peu la
donne
les gens sont de plus en plus nomades et
ils partent beaucoup d'étrangers donc on
a dû voilà quand je prépare ce sera très
important on veut qu'aujourd'hui pour
parce qu'on peut on va être à 14 % de la
population active salariée
donc ça fait déjà plusieurs millions de
personnes c'est pas négligeable et c'est
un tout passant de 9 à 14 passes en
quelques années seulement
alors on est venu presque 20 ans à
atteindre du pur sang ça marche les
entreprises commencent à comprendre à
leurs intérêts mais on l'a vu contre
fallu le russe que le pain béni pour un
sommet à mettre en place des formules
plus ou moins on bricolait de tout le
travail la loi tepa passion les
dispositifs techniques n'étaient pas
prévus par o2 pas expérimentaux pourquoi
on est très vite compris que s'il y
avait eu vraiment la pandémie c'était le
seul moyen de continuer d'avoir des
activités économiques en france notre
faux pas ce qu'on fait la réalité un
jour ou l'autre à un vrai problème il
faudra que le travail est donc mettons
en place maintenant à la merci beaucoup
faisant comme non
depuis maintenant trois ans didier
chappe travail le mercredi de chez lui
ce n'est pas sur le temps de transport
qu'il souhaitait et gagner didier
n'habite qu'à 15 minutes de son
entreprise mais il souhaitait surtout
une meilleure organisation de sa vie
familiale et davantage de moments avec
ses deux filles
ça a été possible grâce aux spécificités
de votre travail laissé dans votre
fonction s'est posé de bonnes questions
aussi et savoir qu'est ce qu'il était
possible de faire pendant ces jo ont été
travaillées ce qui était vraiment
bloquant pour sa de programmer des
usines de mécanique pour en fabriquer
des boîtes de vitesse et les moteurs
finalement on peut le faire au travail
ou aussi si ça ne change absolument rien
après il a suffi d'une organisation bien
précises tout au long de la semaine et
par exemple
de traiter de la facturation canton à
domicile c'est typiquement pas possible
il suffit juste de décalé d'une journée
ou deux ou d'anticiper à la limite cette
tâche là pour pouvoir la traiter son
problème et se consacrait du coup cette
journée télétravail reste on reste à
faire une organisation vite acquise
comme didier 1146 salariés de renault
travail de 1 à 4 jours à leur domicile
on est justement ici chez vous devant
votre poste de travail vous vous
retrouvez les conditions de votre bureau
exactement les mêmes en fait j'ai un
téléphone
j'ai un petit à une petite carte comme
celle ci qui permet de se connecter en
fait au réseau de l'entreprise les
conditions préalables c'est à l'adsl
et puis s'assurer que la maison aux
normes électriquement parlant et à
partir de là tout va changer rien c'est
exactement pareil qu'au travail
téléphone virtuel a accès au dossier
partagé son salon devient son deuxième
bureau et télétravailleurs et managers
s'accordent sur un point la productivité
est au rendez vous a priori même d'après
ce qu'on entend beaucoup plus efficace
en fait on a une certaine sérénité
d'abord on est dans un cadre agréable
puisque l on est chez soi
non pas que le héros ne sera pas
agréable non plus mais voilà on l'a tout
à portée de la main aussi donc
finalement ont dernièrement temps ne
serait-ce que pour déjeuner tout était
prêt au bureau en fait nous sommes à
notre espèce on les vingtaine de
personnes donc imaginez un peu est ce
que ça peut se produire quand tout le
monde est au téléphone et puis quand les
communications sont pas forcément bonnes
on oublie un peu quand on a quelqu'un à
deux mètres à côté alors que là non je
suis tout seul mais bien le calme
à l'image de didier 86% en étaient les
travailleurs de renault ont opté pour un
à deux jours de télétravail pas plus
pour beaucoup le rapport avec les
collègues et l'ambiance du bureau
restent importants d'accord demain je
vous rappelle au plus tôt merci au
revoir
du côté du technocentre on tente de
mettre en avant cette démarche
en un an le nombre de télétravailleurs a
augmenté de 40% sur l'hexagone père
écoute et bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
référent télétravail chez renault la
fenêtre société propose à ses
collaborateurs de travail
un ou plusieurs jours à domicile depuis
2007 absolument quel encadrement
existe-t-il est-ce que c'est finalement
à la carte
ce qu'il faut en aval l'accord fondateur
de janvier 2007 précise très
rigoureusement ce que cela est le
télétravail à domicile sur le
volontariat dans les fondamentaux de
l'accord l'accord bien sûr du
hiérarchique n + 1 qui doit partager le
projet du collaborateur de travail et
incidents entre son domicile et son lieu
de travail habituel
objectif affiché permettre aux salariés
de concilier vie professionnelle et vie
personnelle mais l'entreprise
il trouve bien d'autres avantages des
accidents de trajet c'est une part
importante des accidents de travail
quand on se déplace pas on risque moins
d'accidents de la route
bono logique a évidemment quand on se
déplace pas eh bien on ne pollue pas
quand vous avez économisé de nombreux
kilomètres grâce au télétravail alors on
peut donner effectivement l'évaluation
faite en 2012 des télétravailleurs de
l'époque
compte tenu de nos jours en td travail
de leurs distances ont économisé 9
millions de kilomètres donc ça doit
faire pas mal de co2 et puis un dernier
point finalement les salariés sont du
coup plus efficace c'est effectivement
ce qui ressort de toutes les enquêtes
internes que nous faisons comme cela
ressort des études qui sont faites par
des spécialistes à l'extérieur mais
salariés en télétravail
eh bien ils sont plus efficaces plus
motivé et c'est un levier quelque part
de télétravail de performances
individuelles et collectives et le côté
merci beaucoup
sept mois
nous voici au centre de co-organiser
miro un centre où peuvent se retrouver
les travailleurs nomades pour avoir un
espace de travail en dehors de leur
domicile
il vient d'ouvrir suivez moi cet espace
de coworking a pris place dans la
pépinière d'entreprises des mureaux 20%
des bâtiments n'étaient pas occupés
alors le syndicat intercommunal qui gère
ces locaux a souhaité élargir son public
et s'adapter aux nouvelles modalités de
travail
michel vignier mon jour jour vous êtes
le président du sydom vous êtes donc en
charge de cet espace de coworking à qui
vous adresser mes temps alors on
s'adresse aux jeunes créateurs qui
justement trouve qu'ils ont des charges
trop lourdes quand il rentre en
pépinière donc là il achète du temps de
travail
un espace donné ça peut être des grosses
entreprises
on a là des personnes dont le siège est
en allemagne donc travaillent à
l'étranger qui ont besoin de base sur la
région l'ile-de-france et puis il y à
des entreprises parisiennes alors il ya
des gens qui travaillaient chez eux mais
toujours quand on est chez soi
il ya un moment où vient il faut faire
le goûter des enfants faire les courses
on finit par mélanger un peu le temps et
de se retrouver dans un espace dédié en
se disant voilà je vais passer trois
heures c'est les trois heures de travail
quand on rentre à la maison on mélange
pas tout et va de la gare chercher un
centre de télétravail depuis deux ans
date où elle s'est mise à son compte
d'un côté elle ne voulait plus
travailler sur paris pour rester proche
de son domicile et éviter les temps du
transport à rallonge de l'autre être
tous les jours chez elle ne lui
convenait pas tac une fois deux fois par
semaine c'est gérable on va dire
peut-être à domicile mais
c'est un autre esprit je pense que venir
on sort vraiment du contexte domicile on
sort on a l'impression qu'on va
travailler sauf que ça à côté c'est plus
motivant plus on rencontre des personnes
dont on parle et on peut discuter des
difficultés qu'on peut rencontrer ses
bureaux partagés permettent aussi de se
créer un réseau une fois plus nombreux
l'été les travailleurs pourront être
regroupés par secteur d'activité
malgré les va-et-vient possible la
sécurité des données de chacun a été
pensé chacun a sa session et peut pas
aller dans les sessions des autres et
notre serveur il y a trois systèmes de
sécurité pour ne pas perdre des
informations mais c'est étanche
c'est à dire qu'un voisin peut pas
utiliser les informations de l'autre des
casiers fermée à clé et déposer tous les
soirs dans une remise sont aussi
disponibles en plus de ces bureaux
sécurisés
une salle de repos une salle de réunion
sont à disposition 133 mètres carrés
aménagé au total de nombreux
investisseurs publics ont participé à ce
projet alors comment ses réparties peu
les dépenses le budget de coworking
c'est au tour de 50000 euros
la région a mis 13 1940 euros et le
conseil général
17000 691 euros c'est à dire en gros ils
ont mis les deux institutions le conseil
régional conseil général 50 % de la
totalité du projet votre objectif c'est
les 30 à la conférence on est dans
l'inconnu on fait un pari on fait un
pari pour nous si sur les trois ans qui
viennent on arrive à créer le tourneur
et surtout s'est ensuite orienté vers
les autres bureaux de la pépinière quand
les gens partent ou vers les hôtels
d'entreprises
je pense que sur les trois ans doit
rentrer dans notre rentabiliser le
système c'est un impératif ou à vous
avez des fonds publics qui vous
permettent de tenir malgré ça on a les
communes de toute façon nous demande
d'être en autofinancement dans les trois
ans pour le moment trois personnes ont
intégré l espace de coworking
mais le cidem a déjà reçu une
dizaine de demandes et ce chiffre
devrait gonfler d'ici la rentrée de
septembre
c'est la fin de ce fil est qu merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve pour un
prochain numéro le 28 juin